die retter kommen vom himmel
der träger verstanden
15.000 einsätze pro jahr für menschen in
not
im sekt und helikopter
im in und ausland
das ist die rega
arbeitsbeginn bei reger 10 in wilderswil
rettungssanitäter marcolli arzt tommy
von will
und pilot ricco war er kontrolliert wie
jeden morgen seine maschine daily check
des tankers best of the best ist es so
dass er die pause setzte helle als
wirklich zum honky tonk oft ganz auf das
ist es auch wieder wegnahm und ich finde
das so gut da lockt man zudem helle dass
israel das ist er gott sah dass kennt
solchen rt wird im flieger alphabet zu
romeo tango
er wird reger 10 nicht am boden bleiben
es ist der erste schöne frühlingstag
am flughafen zürich in der zentrale der
erreger werden alle helikopter
koordiniert einsatzleiterin geht die
kuhn tritt den dienst an auf welchen
gletscher sind sie ein gletscher und auf
welcher höhe das knie ist eine landung
möglich regelsatz steigt
recht lässig antworten
nur in
jeder handgriff sitzt in fünf minuten
muss roman tango in der luft sein
ja
wir werden den helikopter schicken
standards sind unterwegs richtig
steinbrecher city möglich 76 sekunden
romy t signal in offenbach
in der luft prüft die crew die genauen
koordinaten des unfallautos übermittelt
vom rega center
hey
die erweiterung gestellt
eine landung beim verunfallten
skitourenfahrer ist unmöglich
art tommy von wil und rettungssanitäter
marke steigen aus dem schwebenden
helikopter pilot rick maurer fliegt in
standby position
ich hab das knie verdreht und kann nicht
mehr aufstehen bewegen nicht richtig ich
kann das knie nicht mehr bieten sonst
hast du keine verletzung hast du
allergien nein das ist ein schmerzmittel
es ist sehr stark rettungssanitäter
marke steigt wieder in den helikopter um
die winde zu bedienen
es wird ziemlich gelassen nachher
wir werden uns nicht mehr verstehen
medien
der pilot hat während der winden rettung
keinen sichtkontakt zu patient und arzt
der muss sich ganz auf die angaben von
marx allee an der winter verlassen
sieht einfach aus ist es aber nicht
diese präzision erfordert viel training
und erfahrung
ein paar hundert meter weiter unten
landet der heli und lädt den patienten
ein
interlaken ist das heim spital von reger
hier landet romeo tango oft mehrmals pro
tag
und hier arbeitet tommy von wil als
leitender arzt neben seiner tätigkeit
bei der rega
kaum ist der patient ausgestiegen trifft
in der zentrale der nächste notruf ein
es bleibt nicht viel zeit
der nächste fall wartet es geht wieder
um einen skitourenfahrer fast am
gleichen ort
und schon ist riga ziehen wieder in der
luft
den takt gibt die einsatzzentrale
helikopter in zürich wo rund um die uhr
geht die coolen leidet ein team von 20
mitarbeitern man aber er ist nicht
verletzt
ihr wisst es nicht sie müssen eine winde
einsetzen ok unter wasser aber er ist
nicht allein dort gehst du ihn holen
okay die crew ist unterwegs zwischen 2
stein und dem irgendwie ändert sich für
werte vor ort und erschöpft habe ich
bewusst sind aber langsam durch immer
noch im wasser
neben der regel sind rund 30
rettungskräfte am unfallort im einsatz
draußen vor dem rega center trifft
jetpilot philipp sémon bringt
zum gleichen team gehört auch
pflegefachfrau yvonne horisberger
sie wurde am vorabend für diesen einsatz
aufgeboten
ja shops und ich halte es auch linie
menschlich geholl es knapp als kilo 800
m herr ich sie mir immer schon immer die
energie bringen
das winzige baby braucht einen 100 kilo
schweren brutkasten der in den jet
eingebaut werden muss
pilot philipp sémon pakt mit seinem co
piloten an
nicht zum ersten mal 7 arbeitet seit
zwölf jahren für die rega schon bald
solle zum kapitän befördert werden
hierarchie stufen und funktionen hin
oder her im chat arbeiten alle hand in
hand zusammen mit dem kinderarzt bauen
die piloten den brutkasten 1
flight neusiedl horisberger kann für
diesen flug auf die unterstützung einer
pflegefachfrau neonatologie des
kinderspitals zürich zählen die letzten
vorbereitungen
die erfahrene intensiv pflegefachfrau
hat nicht nur medizinische aufgaben
sie ist auch für die verpflegung
zuständig eine allrounderin
liga ziehen ist beim zweiten skitouren
unfall des tages eingetroffen
der patient ist auf den arm gestoppt
wahrscheinlich ist die schulter
ausgerenkt
es geht ins spital interlaken
heute.de
dieser ambulanzjet wird frühchen juli in
athen abholen
der abflug steht kurz bevor
schlusspfiff in die einsatzleitung at
liefert alle details zu flug- und
patientin ihr werdet abgeholt am
flughafen von ambulanz und einmal zu der
begleiter wenn ihr kind schlecht
vielmehr hängt einerseits mutter vor ort
mission auf der linie häuser
sie hat ein koffer unter hompesch adobe
den händen markus michael niederhäuser
er hat ein großes und ein notebook das
ist das ist
philipp sémon wird nicht nur vom co
piloten sondern auch von einem
instruktor begleitet zum letzten mal vor
seiner beförderung zum captain
noch ist die rolle auf der linken
kopfseite neu für ihn
man ist positiv so strahler sein willst
dann gottes auf 20 über unter gesprochen
lega-chef pilot aus nagel hat auf den
job sieht platz genommen er bildet felix
7 aus
aber keine panik
die wand
projekt
rettung
start richtung athen
in der heli einsatzzentrale ist die
stimmung gedämpft
der verunfallte kanufahrer konnte nicht
gerettet werden
viel zeit zum verarbeiten bleibt nicht
verletzt eine musikalische mich
unverletzt
das team von rega ziehen dass gerade den
tourenskifahrer im spital abgeliefert
hat macht sich auf den weg richtung
erlenbach im simmental genaue
koordinaten fehlen
es ist eine suche aus der luft eine
erfolgreiche suche
für art tommy von willis schnell klar es
wird ein kampf ums leben
vom reanimieren
58 2 und meter die geräte stellspieler
schlager in der ganzen schlosshotel
zucker naka 7
so lautet der medizinische code für
einen todesfall alltag für die crew von
reger 10
aber keine routine wenn wir jetzt aus
einer krise wie schlimm es passiert
sondern immer nur also mich zumindest in
recht parieren im moment wenn man
hoffentlich den karrieren abschalten
sich auf das wesentliche fokussieren
nach events sowie stehen
tut man sich gedanken machen
mich bei jetzt 1
die nachricht von ak 7 in erlenbach
lässt auch die kuh nicht kalt
das klingt der rega ambulanzjet ist
mittlerweile hoch über den wolken
wer genau
dies bringt
philipp sémon hat kaum zeit zum essen
der instruktor nimmt den in beschlag
die pisten zahl in thessaloniki ist nur
eine von vielen wissensfragen die
medizinische crew bespricht einzuleiten
der repatriierung
herr stunde wurde zustand ist doch
beschrieben für den zweiten finalisten
schwangerschaftswochen inzwischen zieht
sich kreismeister stabil
die schienen alle selber leid neues
horisberger ist in ihrem element
etwa 70 tage pro jahr verbringt sie in
der luft
würzburg bewegt
dass putin bei einem besuch in athen
arbeiten wird der ambulanz ist es nicht
mehr erlaubt auf den korb zu kommen das
händlern vor ort wird sich darum kümmern
dass sie euch zu der ambulanz dem
eindringen
es gibt vielfach in russland sei ein
präsident putin zukunft an
wir wissen was man macht berufsrichter
oder
kommt wladimir putin der rega und baby
jury in die quere
rega 10 ist zurück auf der basis in
wilderswil um neues medizinisches
material zu holen und zu kommen
eine tankfüllung reicht für etwa eine
stunde und 20 minuten flugzeit tankwart
ist rettungssanitäter kohle er
unterstützt nicht nur den arzt sondern
auch den piloten eine betrügerische
sieht dort die medizinische jedes
crewmitglied hat seine aufgaben
es ist mittagszeit auf der basis und
meistens ddr meister sieht zum kochen
und dann durch wochenende
eigentlich hat damit leiste zur sonne
leiter gestimmt oder brauner der
gastprofessur mutig maurer hat sich
hinter büroarbeiten gemacht er ist nicht
nur pilot sondern auch leiter der basis
mit zwölf mitarbeitern immer auch
einfach später muss das natürlich gold
wird mitarbeiter sprach ein jahren mit
der tag stellte hier qualifikation
slogan dass das sei oft werden
das thema the gate oder welt am sonntag
follett einfach das und das macht also
215 verzahnte macht meines noch eine
parallele zum zum bäcker den stabilitas
natürlich
der rega chat ist in athen gelandet
die zeit drängt werden noch sind die
chancen offen
die ambulanz konnte vorfahren aber
irgendwann wird deswegen präsident
putins besuch kein durchkommen mehr
geben
und während knappe stunde um zwei
stunden auch eine fenstergröße
straßensperre planen diese habe kräfte
wecken später zum flughafen
jetzt wird man sorge dass man auch
wirklich steht ist sie verblieben
besseren aber recht schnell auch endlich
übergaben spital machen
der verkehr in athen hat es auch ohne
sperren im sich aber schließlich trifft
die ambulanz im materialität spital und
bei den eltern von julie bringen
doch nicht
jonas
vor 13 tagen ist juli zur welt gekommen
die eltern durften sie bisher nur zwei
mal pro tag eine halbe stunde lang sehen
um sind überglücklich dass die jury in
die schweiz nehmen dürfen
der zweite vorname von geely ist athene
als erinnerung an den abenteuerlichen
start ins leben
trotz der eile
vor dem aufbruch will der rega arzt
genau wissen wie es geht
auf keinen fall möchte und ricks
kamischli im verkehr blockiert werden
si
wir sind jetzt zum spital los in der
ambulanz fahrer richtig flughafen
wenn jetzt also nach plan laufe könnten
maximal halb stunde und wenn sie es
wieder verändert unterwegs denn
natürlich der noch schalker juli und das
rega team haben glück sie kommen ohne
verzögerung zum flughafen
wladimir putin ist noch nicht
eingetroffen
ok
strom abhängen
die branche noch stärker
im rega center in zürich ist der
ereignisreiche tag noch nicht
abgeschlossen
wie sau
bei reger 10 finden die putzarbeiten ein
rasches ende
der hardau hausberg von internaten
befindet sich gleich gegenüber der basis
ein katzensprung mit dem helikopter und
ich verbinde
ich war die verbindung mit dem pilot
weiß wo sich die bewusste sie probiert
haben hofft immer verspürt und dann
stellen sie genau das fünfte und
im rega ambulanzjet verschläft juli
athene ihrem ersten flug
soll ich dir
foto trier
nicht nur das baby auch seine eltern
kommen zur ruhe und haben zeigt die
erlebnisse revue passieren zu lassen
ich boxe
red
habe ich aus wut wird es morgen nummer
teams standen wir
die odyssee beginnt als bei der mutter
in den ferien auf naxos plötzlich die
fruchtblase platzt das spital dort ist
für frühgeburten nicht eingerichtet die
familie wird nach langen diskussionen
mit einem militärhelikopter nach athen
gebracht den vierjährigen sohn louis
rollt die großmutter ab und bringt ihn
in die schweiz
julia telekom per kaiserschnitt zur welt
jetzt ist im anflug auf die schweiz und
auch philipp siemens letzter flug vor
der beförderung geht zu ende
der sinkflug nach bern
das krankenauto wird juli ins
inselspital bringen
für den piloten ist die mission hier zu
ende
so neu und die ganze familie stehen für
den empfang bereit
richtig zufrieden
ja
in der nächsten folge als tommy von
wildsteig zur verunfallten frau im
hardter wald ab eine schwierige rettung
nach ihrer repatriierung bekommen sie
und ihre mutter besucht vom sozial- und
betreuungsdienst erreger wie patrick
maurer kämpft für seine linie